two American women who were stranded
from months at sea are now safe on land
Jennifer Appel and Tasha fou Yahveh
arrived in Japan this morning it was the
first time they set foot on solid ground
for nearly six months a Navy ship
rescued them on Wednesday after they
drifted for thousands of miles in the
Pacific Ocean
Jericka Duncan is here with new
information on their nightmare journey
Jericka good morning good morning
Jennifer Appel says she began planning
to sail from Hawaii to Tahiti two and a
half years ago but despite all of that
preparation she now admits she had no
idea what she was getting into the crew
of the USS Ashland saved our lives
safe in the hands of the US Navy
Jennifer Appel and Tasha phooey OVA
weren't shy to express their gratitude
the women and their two dogs were
rescued Wednesday after an 18 day
journey swelled into a five month long
crisis seeing other boats and then
seeing them turn away from us was just
heartbreaking we got to a point where we
actually rode in the log we've been left
for dead a Taiwanese fishing vessel
discovered the women on Tuesday 900
miles southeast of Japan they say their
engine died and the 50 foot sailboat had
drifted some 5,000 miles from their
original course from Hawaii to Tahiti
when we saw the Navy we're like yes
someone who can actually help us the
crew admits they had faced problems with
their equipment including their radio
from the start of their trip here is
Maui Shh
storm Shh okay turn away from Maui
not realizing that the antenna was
already messed up and we were turning
directly into the storm yeah that him
away from it
they say they collided with near
hurricane-force winds and refused to
turn around a piece of the mass broke
limiting the craft steering and speed
another storm they say flooded the boats
engine and disabled communications Appel
says the crippled vessel eventually
drifted into a group of aggressive tiger
sharks and the tiger sharks figured that
we had entered their living room and we
were not leaving fast enough as the
challenge is mounted Appel and fooey OVA
looked to their canine crewmates Zeus
and Valentine for support I'm telling
you right now without those two we'd
have been nuts I mean way more nuts than
we already are the woman also credit
their survival with a water purifier and
as much of a year's worth of extra food
that they packed their sailboat the sea
nymph is still floating out there in the
ocean Appel says she would actually like
to try and recover it and sail to Tahiti
next spring so after all that she wants
to go again I know in our friends and
family going what's wrong with you no
way survived all of that to go through
that again I don't know they loved being
out there on the water you won't find me
a bit like pulling off your horse and
then getting back on yeah I'm having
scenes of castaway that movie like how
it could have really ended up you know
yeah all right so much thank you jury
car